[音楽]
[拍手]
みなさんが普段のものをどれだけ自分で作ってますか
例えば
スプーンとがイスとかあとこういう建物ナンバーは
仲間と自分や蔵ないんですよねだってどうやって作ったらいいかわからないし
買っちゃえば済む話だしでも野生の縁というのは自分の性自分で作ることができます
私たちも昔はいろんな道やすぐ場所を自分で作ってました
世の中がどんどん便利になるとそういう野生の使って退化していっちゃうんでしょうか
私は圏地下ですああこういう世界だったらいいなぁと思うのをたまたパッと自分でで山
して実際に作ったときもすごい強い喜びを感じます
なぜならあー ti は私の手で作れるんだ
そんな強い自信を持てるからです
どうしたらみんなにこの素晴らしい喜びをシェアできるかなーと思いながら
建築やアートを作る仕事をこれまでして言っているんですがその時必ず弊害になって
いうのがこの専門領域という
クローイ深い謎の海です
みんなで落ち作ろうよという呼びかけても弥生研地下じゃないからそんなで枚岩とか
そういう資格持ってなんだ出来ませんって調整する前からみんな
躊躇して辞めてしまうんです
大丈夫会を取り今じゃないよとドーンと突き落としたいんですけれども
もしやすぎてその人は溺れて大失敗したらもう二度と
挑戦しようと思ってくれません
それは先なきゃいけない
そこで
プロの力が必要かなぁと思いまー
黒っていうのは失敗の成功も飛びがたくさんの平均の引き出しを持っている人です
だから初めてを呼ぶ人にもこうやったらいいよ
こうやって声で動く言っていくよといろんなアドバイスをしてあげることが出来るし
万が一その人が折れそうになったらじゃんっ
さしてがあって当てることができます
もしそんな風に大丈夫ここなら安全だよと楽しく誰かが見守っていてくれば誰でも自由
にそこで泳いでどんどん良いが上達するかもしれん
創造力を育む場というのもまさにこれと同じなんですね
実際の例をご紹介されています
私はこれまでふみかなザンビアという国で
をさんの施設地域の人が自分たちで作ることを応援羞恥ゴツンしてきました
日本の40代の人区三ヶ尾さんでなくなってしまうという深刻な殉教があるので
こういう中国のコンテナにメールして
お産本質を村グラムみんなで作っていくんですが
11私が飛んで行くとお金も時間もたくさんかかってもったいない
だからどうしたらこの普通 prova リアルプロセスに住民ウッドにキュヒョンと
入って一緒に
をよくそれをやってきました
大体私はて打ったというのはこういう図面を変えて設計を始めるですが行きなるこの爪
を真に強い人にチャレンジしたしてもらうのはなかなかリスクがあることです
そこで私が考えたのは
この制約のなかいいえ
自由に遊んでもらうことです
これは大丈夫この範囲の中ならどんな自由に行ってもいいを
という安全地帯を用意してあげることです
例えばその一つがほえ
これは直月模型キットと私がよっのでこの髪を切って組み立ててペタペタ貼っていけば
誰でも気がつくとまたリティーハウスの設計ができて出ちゃってる
そういうものです
ポン中前的な知識をいろいろを使わなきゃいけないんですがそれは楽しい歌と踊りで
みんなで知識をシェアしあって
覚えていますか
沿って遊び心漫才まあショップをやっていたら
初めて参加した地元打ったしてもたった数時間でまたリリーハウスの設計を終わらせる
ことができました
もう一つの遊びは枝ペターぱっぱースタンプです
これは寄ってきたったに偏諱を塗って
て食べたと今でな表面にん
デコレーションしていく作業です
これも動画に絵が苦手な人でも誰でも敬遠しや
仕上げることができるそう ei からです
とっても楽しいので9みんなが参加してくれて今が素敵な方へ tears が発生し
ました
実際にとってもダミーなった方が施設に生で4よりもずっと多くの人が泊まりに来て
安全の山を体験してくれることになります
このように楽しくさんからしてもらうしたてはうまくできたんですがもっともっと
彼らが持っている exo 的な
才能を発揮してもらいたいなぁと思って
制約を少し外すことをほころんでいました
家に2軒目のまたリティーハウスのデザインを考えてもらった
スルド出てきたのが
こういう2つないでした
どうしようこんな難しい ao どうやって大きい壁にかかってないんだろう
できるかなちょっと高い山は想定しちゃったかなぁ
私も心配だったんですがなんとか黒の位置でですね
みんながその目標の山に登れるための見えないはしごにな
みんなを支えて登らず飲んでいることをします持って行ってもらうことをやってみまし
た
例えば
下書きを書く作業というのはちょっと難しいので我々プロがだいぶサポートしたのです
がそれ以外の作業を担いどんどん挑戦してもらえます
天気へえをかいても作業は筆の使い方をないと終わらないと失敗してぐちゃぐちゃに
なっちゃうので
最初は1本の筆と1色のペンキ刷毛は私て
とに家政婦をひたすら書く楽しさに夢中になってもらいました
男装ハッピー筆塚得ないと言うと今度は皆
色を付けたりして遊び始めます
例えば森とは
何か模様費等がかかっことに夢中になりました
他の人は色といった実て何かカーン踏まえを出すことに興味を持ち始めました
この人は
塩定例でいくことに夢中になってました
こうやって一人ずつの個性が見えてるがチャンスです
とにかく褒めて米で伸ばして褒めて持ち上げます
じゃああなたもそも4使いこんな
コンプラコンプロレスは日本人では作れないなぁとか
御目沢山の藻塩ヶ月なんてあなたの根拠は本当に素晴らしいわ
正門的でかつ
やってくれたことへの感謝をとにかく受けさんに伝えていきます
千葉いい先ほども見えないはしごというのは一人一人の個性にあった
一人ひとりの目標に向かってオーダーメイドで作っ
here ことに興味があるかああ麻痺阿蘇を
ひぁっを差し出していく国金先生が教えてくれた変化た
無事になりましたという受け日の学びはなって
あくまでも自分でやってみたいと思ってしちゃったよ
いう能動な青黒的
さあこの役にまだリハウスので際の形が出来上がったので次はどうやってこれを多くの
地域に広げていこうかと考えましたん
その時私1人ではなくて地元のみんなの経験者自分たちでほしいに具という
ていました
そのときにああこれとっても大事なんだなって思ったことは2つています
一つは
身近な英雄への憧れです
これはねっ
隣村のあんな人ができたのっていう意外性と
後親近感
例えば萌え読者さんはさん現金の子へ行ったときに私の中でもねちょっと大丈夫よ
みんなもできるそうやってありましたん
せっその暗くトラああ僕も彼女みたいになって次のない
応援しに行きたいなそんなモチベーションにつながります
あるいは
他続筆は
150またリティーハウスを見たい人が
たいなぁ自分たちで作れるんじゃないかと思って自分たちの卜部
触れてないそう
自分で集めたお金と自分達集まっ
a
今が席まだアイディア自分たちの手で作ってしまいました
そうしようと人でもできるんだそういう純粋な驚きが
ほかの人をどんどんインスパイアーさせてくるんですね
その成功体験の物語が人を勇気づけるんでしょ
この日やがうわぁ凄いね人も
節もできるかしらなんかすごいわねぇそうやってお互いの成功
褒め方やそういう風土こそこの想像力ももっともっとみんなにインスパイア広がって
いるために重要なんだということを
なられました
なぜかというと私たち黒はとかく
あーもルピーででちゃってあぁ今回も二重たなぁ
何か完成しても彼女たちにために大喜びすることを今私はしてません
反省してます
それからなぁすごいに私もできたんだっていうふうに純正に感動しできたのっていうの
は
[音楽]
不思議なことにその場所にもそのものにもその気持ちがずーっとも凝るんです
だからそれで胴体ともそこに住む人も何私もできるかな
私の作ってみようそういうふうに勇気付けあっていく
素晴らしい力を持っているんですね
このみんなの修復の大きなムードの中で今私が他パールなくも
true tears の建築が年に一剣つつ
ジャンビアで行われていると聞いています
そう皆さんもご存じだと思いますが身の回りに必要なものを作るのは決して専門官しか
できないのではありません
どんな人にもいつでも
ことでも何歳になっても愛せ焼くこと
私はみんながその身にバーンとと見込むための背中ハウス
てに成田市
そしてをしていきたいと大丈夫だよと受け止める
安心の死球でまた医師
たまにその服バッチ登りたいというのを影で支え味後にもらえたらしいっ
あるいはたまにははすごいなあって呼ばれる存在にもだしたへ
そしていつも貧打を日焼け跡応援するそんな時間いっぱい
そう思えます
なぜかというとその一つ一つであることが私にとってはこの上ない喜びなんです
あ自分今すごく粋大妃がせる
なんか前で店カーをれてきた美しい光の中に今自分
住まれているような気がするそんな幸せに行き私はいつも鍛えることができるからです
ありがとうございます